all right so Ryan as you mentioned the
wet weather is really creating some
hazardous driving conditions Mary Jane
bellies are continuing our team coverage
Mary Jane is live near Desert Inn in
Valley View with a look at the
conditions in that area
and you know when there's rain in the
forecast that could impact your commute
as the rain can cause low visibility and
also affect travel time
rain slick roads and fast drivers are a
recipe for disaster Nevada State Police
tweeting out deadly crashes across the
valley and Advising drivers to slow down
according to the Federal Highway
Administration 21 percent of vehicle
crashes each year in the United States
are weather related of those crashes 73
percent were linked to wet pavement and
46 percent due to rain you have to keep
a longer distance between the car ahead
of you you have to anticipate if you
accelerate the car will sleep changing
lanes you have to do it more careful so
it's a lot of factors that people need
to pay attention when they drive in rain
Victor butnari owner of universal motor
car says he sees more cars come into a
shop after the rain people get in Iraq
the cars are Slip slippery and Vegas
like the asphalt releases a lot of
grease and it's it's an increase of
numbers after the rain he recommends to
maintain your windshield wipers and to
double check your tire tread minimum on
the rain it's recommended to be the 432s
but more than that it's recommended the
key is the tires that's why the cars
sleep especially when they brake when
they accelerate and cause an accident
meteorologist John Adair from the
national weather service in Las Vegas
has been busy tracking the weather and
forecasting what else is to come it does
look like even next week there's another
potential large specific system looming
way out Beyond a week but we are looking
at it so we're not even done yet it
doesn't look like it no the active
Pacific storm pattern continues
and again as you've heard with more
active weather on the way now is the
time to make sure that you're double
checking your tire tread and also
replacing those windshield wipers I saw
at least one accident on my way to work
this morning which definitely caused
some backups remember to take it slow
out on the roads there